une poupée qui répond lorsqu'on lui pose
une question
un ourson en peluche qui nous avise
qu'il est l'heure de dormir
un chien qui obéit à nos ordres utiliser
des applications pour connecter les
jouets à l'internet qui ça donne ça
donne à l'enfant la possibilité
d'interagir avec le jouer il est utilisé
l'utilisation de ces jouets connectés
comporte des risques pour la protection
de la vie privée s'est joué leur
permettre une très grande collecte de
données sur lara qui l'utilisent comme
la voit son image toutes sortes de
données sur l'utilisation aussi même la
localisation ou non continuer en 2010
est une agence fédérale allemande a
conseillé aux parents de détruire la
poupée mal fringuée la jugeant que le
périphérique bluetooth permettait un
pirate d'écouté et d'entrer en
communication avec l'enfant
aux etats unis le fbi yahia et cité les
parents à tenir compte des enjeux de
cyber sécurité avant de faire entrer un
jouet connectés dans leurs foyers au
pirate pourrait télécharger toutes ces
données la fusée à toutes sortes
d'autres fins défait par exemple de vol
il y a aussi le marketing
le fabricant cibler des publicités vers
les cellulaires d'écart 1 si vous
possédez un s'est joué voici quelques
règles de sécurité à suivre modifier le
nom d'utilisateur modifier le nom passe
à surveiller les enfants pendant qu'il
joue avec le jouet est au c après une
séance de jeu de déconnecter le jouer
même quand c'est un jeu d'enfant
la vigilance demeure de mise ici valérie
nicolas bay ne radio canada montréal